Google is one of the world's most
profitable companies making tens of
billions of dollars a year in ad sales
but this week it's facing a global
crisis after some of the world's biggest
advertisers suddenly halted their
spending the concern is where their ads
are running sometimes next to offensive
content including videos promoting
terror and anti-semitism here to talk
about the search giant's troubles as
Jason tans editor-at-large for Wired
magazine
Jason so these ads are placed randomly
on videos it's not like the advertisers
can are choosing which videos to attach
the ads to yeah that's right this is
kind of a problem of both too much
technology and not enough right so so
the deal is Google has opened up to
allow programmatic advertising which is
automatically placed across thousands
and thousands and thousand millions of
sites and YouTube as well places ads
programmatic programmatically on
millions of videos this is not a human
being going through and deciding which
ad matches up with which video and the
problem is that when you do that
sometimes the AI fails and the a guy
doesn't always catch offensive material
and then you end up with AT&T being
advertised against material it doesn't
wanna be advertised against or Johnson &
Johnson and some of the world's biggest
advertisers okay so how what does Google
do about this they released a statement
saying this week they are reviewing ad
policies and plan to make changes to
give advertisers more control over where
their ads appear how feasible is that
given the amount of content that we're
talking about well it's a hard problem I
mean part of what Google said they're
doing is they're hiring more engineers
to fix the AI which doesn't seem like a
very quick fix yeah on the other hand
their initial response was somewhat
passive-aggressive it was the kind of
like I'm sorry if I offended you
response like I'm sorry our tools
weren't simple enough for you boneheads
to use they've step back from that a
little bit and what they say is that you
know this is just a few things that fall
through the cracks
for the most part 99% of offensive
material is properly flagged and does
not get advertised against but that
doesn't really work that well you need
to be batting a thousand if you if
you're a big company like Johnson &
Johnson you want to make sure your ads
are appearing only where you want them
to exactly and that's what the
advertisers are saying they're pulling
their ads from YouTube maybe they're
pulling their ads from the entire
programmatic platform until Google can
absolutely guarantee 100% that their ads
will not
appear against offensive content now the
problem with that is that if you take
paint with too broad a brush if they
become very conservative and say we're
gonna err on the side of not advertising
then you become an arbiter for what's
offensive and what's not offensive and
different voices can be shut out or not
making money because Google's being too
cautious so it's a really difficult
position that they're in it's one
they've tried to avoid getting in to be
honest with you and you were saying
earlier that that there's 400 hours of
videos uploaded every minute onto
YouTube hey I don't see how they can
please that even with AI and do they
look for like Wikipedia does do they
look at users to help flag these kinds
of offensive contents yeah that's right
and they look at the way that you know
these videos are titled they look at the
descriptions that people use so those
things can also be you know those things
can be manipulated as well we all know
from the entire industry built up around
search engine optimization that you can
you can tweak things to appear to be
things they're not so that is also a
very tricky situation I mean the way a
lot of this has worked Facebook has
employed you know armies of content
moderators to go through any flagged
material and determine whether or not
it's offensive or not the other problem
is that these are global platforms and
different countries have you know
different kind of ethical rubrics and so
there is no one answer for everyone the
other place this gets really hard is for
instance LGBTQ stuff is that offensive
it should that be that they've already
run into problems with that well then it
becomes a problem of censorship right
and as much that dovetails with this
whole thing from a revenue perspective
when you're talking about these brands
putting the pressure on Google how
meaningful is that for in terms of the
bottom line so they don't actually break
out the numbers right now by far the
bulk of Google's advertising revenue
comes from its search ads which are not
impacted by this at all but the that's
been true for a really long time and
Google has been very much attempting to
develop different kinds of products
going forward and a lot of the growth is
in video a lot of the growth is in
YouTube and a lot of the growth is in
programmatic so it may not hugely impact
their bottom line right now but this is
where all the growth is so they really
do need to get it figured out so if not
the present than the future correct all
right wires chase enchants thanks a lot
thank you